herzlich willkommen im video ist jetzt
zusammen mit sebastian und mit studiert
und ihr werdet schon im titel gesehen
haben wir haben heute mit der fei sap
verschiedene youtuber vorbereitet bzw
wie wird einheits stunden vorbereiten
dafür könnt ihr jetzt schon mal leichter
lassen er ist vielleicht dass wir mit
der fei sap leute ziemlich verunstalten
kann ich glaube ich demonstriert dass
man kurz so wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal
zum beispiel dieses foto von dgb dafür
machen wir einen screenshot und jetzt
ohne viel zu gucken habe ich nichts
gesehen
ihr kennt ja im prinzip schon aber ich
nehme es zuerst euch nur noch mal also
ich kann jetzt wie das foto von darlehen
kommen hier mal richtig make-up okay ein
bisschen mehr noch weil wir können
wirklich alles an paare bei diesem foto
verändert wird jetzt schwarze haare
mama papa und anders jetzt kriegt sie
noch ein pony wir finden ja nicht gut
ich würde sagen es spätestens ab diesem
zeitpunkt ab dem zweiten könnte niemand
wäre wenn man halt oben den namen nicht
niemand könnte mir erkennen wer das ist
und das ist der ganze sinn des heutigen
videos acht leute sind vorbereitet und
wir gucken der von uns als erstes errät
gestern wir sind gespannt auf das erste
will was wasser die dafür geräusch wenn
er errät der wir haben einfach auch weil
wir sicher nicht ich hab ich hab' ich
sagen ich hab dich hab es dann und das
geld und das finde ich gut und nicht zu
lange
was ist nämlich gesagt einfach es ist
nein nein klingt ganz nach dem motto
hier
[Musik]
der unterkiefer ist einfach gut oh mein
gott war heute thema sein
ich habe das was ich mir seine schulter
fertig und auch das mal genauer
angeschaut werden das sieht aus wie so
jemand der so die existenz der
bundesrepublik deutschland als vorbild
aus seinem führerhaus war richtig und
freuen glaubt schon weiß ich habe
gesehen dass ich irgendwie traurig aus
kriegs- den punkt noch aber nichts mal
bitte was sie sagen das ist kelly würde
ich sagen ja ich hab ich hatte auch alte
herzlichkeit aus wie gerade eben ja
eigentlich genauso einsitzer häßler ich
muss mir raus fertig habe sie gedacht
wie gut das eins zu eins zu null ab
sofort passen wir nicht mehr habe ich
gerade alle direkt
nein ich habe keine ag liliana di di di
di di di di noia infekt kann von dem 1
regina wechseln ist das muster dem man
seine lieder kennt deswegen so lief die
haare sind nicht echt schwarz glaube ich
natürlich sind die nicht extra zu ihren
privat ist nicht der basis nicht ich
kenne seit der badi etliche blatt weiter
ich stehe so schlau ist jetzt wollte
schwarz von den kommentar hat denn
diesen heftigen bau selbst in etting bat
der box trainiert es ist vielleicht
manchmal auch dürfen ja angenagelt der
jetzt bin ich gespannt
diana
ich habe direkt an bord das sah richtig
warm geworden dass ein bisschen wie das
aussieht wie michaelis kamen mehrere von
harry potter start ins jahr 2010
die leute bei dir ja sowieso wie vor dem
alter es gibt noch mal gesehen ich
glaube ich würde
für den verkehr
naja melina jetzt mit die sieht aus wie
so ein mächtiger zauberer stabilisiert
aber auch auf wiesen löwenbändiger wie
immer der fährt er nach deutschland
wieder videos mit der machen kennen
jemanden uns nicht verkriechen brüche
ist ist aber nun kommt die aufgabe nicht
erklären
das war so denken sie also ganz ehrlich
also ganz ehrlich heute wenn ich eines
tages in die hölle kommen sollte so
stehen für die 25 das wirklich der
brennpunkt weil ich hätte familien im
brennpunkt nach ist der brennpunkt so
dass der teufel und er sagt also abfahrt
auf druck israels prüße eine neue
wachstums geht direkt weiter
das ist noch ein melina alina
nachwuchsleute aus der wieder videos
oder nein
wir müssen darüber reden müsste aber den
was das für wesen sind dreckig war dass
das sieht nicht mehr aus als könnte das
make up machen aber sie
helmut das ist immerhin schon
zusammengenähten sollte aber aber egal
was passiert das henschel blick bleibt
genau wie nicht jeder einfach noch ein
bisschen unzufrieden mit seinem leben
aber er merkt dass er eine rote streben
hat also leute folger maßen damit war
die punkte durchgezählt ich habe zwei
max hatte auch zwei und da haben wir
zeitgleich apa red gesagt dass wir beide
3 punkte also müssen wir noch ganz
schlecht machen wäre es gerade eben
sturm hier leben die kamera gestellt der
macht einfach neues transfer tätigen
maklern in der finalen entscheidung und
dann zeigt sich wer am besten gegen
mutierte youtuber erkennen kann
ich kann mir noch mehrere sachen andere
lachanfall bekommen
antwort der spiegel als cooler es geht
jetzt auch schon fünf minuten alles
braucht so oder so ich kann man noch
mehr machen kann zum alterssitz finale
entscheidung erkennt man noch das ist
ein mensch sein soll freude wenn ihr
jetzt noch dran seid seid ihr nicht nur
die absoluten ehrenmänner sondern hat
auch die möglichkeit die kommentar frage
des heutigen videos sonst hätte ich
schon jemals zuvor gerade beantworten
die ist nämlich heute wie heißt dieses
objekt schreibt es jetzt in die
kommentare
und ich werde sämtliche kommentare licon
die das richtig beantworten
wahrscheinlich wird dann einfach jeder
nur den top kommentare hallo wir sind
minute 10
wie geht es voran es kann nur zwei
sachen interessieren
richtig schnell richtig lange brauche
ich hoffe natürlich zweiteres damit mehr
werbung zu erkennen da für mich okay 3 1
so richtig jahre rocker vom motorrad
klar aber ist auch so wissens herziges
ist wie du glaubst einer kölner
u-bahn-station oder das ist schon mal
wichtig wird das will ja es ist schon so
johanna ja eigentlich das perfekte sieht
aus wie jemand der so schon ein bisschen
schutz gegen nimmt von zu klären so mehr
aber der hat auch so die kinder das
publikum zu teilen
weißt du was mein favourit war das war
als johanna ohne bad wiessee hat echt
aus wie so eine komische weise auch
immer wieder aus
für den fussball mutter die im bioladen
zur wichtigsten aufgabe wartet damit
seit 20 jahren kennt war okay doch dann
würd ich sagen habe ich die erste folge
wenn man soll das gut ankommen und
vielleicht kommt meter folgen von dieser
von dem game hier gewonnene danke an
studien also was dabei sein
vielleicht habt ihr beim nächsten mal
auf dem schoss dann sehen uns im
nächsten video wieder mach's gut und bis
dahin tschüss